these were the final preparations as the
kimball wick hunt in buckinghamshire
readied itself for an annual tradition
that dates back to the 1700s
but there are question marks over
hunting's future
after land owners like the national
trust banned hunts from using their land
and there have been renewed calls for
trail hunting to be outlawed completely
amid allegations it is simply a smoke
screen andrew salas is master of the
foxhounds here and says much of the
opposition is misguided and politically
motivated
hunting a like quarry was banned by a
labour government
back in 2004 and and was replaced by
trail hunting and now they want to ban
trail arctic so is this really about
animal welfare or is it about a set of
politicians who really have got a big
big problem with a large swathe of the
rural community
fox hunting has been illegal in england
and wales since 2004
so instead these hounds follow a scent
that has been laid down something known
as trail hunting
earlier this year a prominent huntsman
was convicted after giving an online
master class on how to break the hunting
act
something campaigners say they had long
suspected was happening anyway
i've seen them hunting with my own eyes
they go out every time to do it and it's
it's a bloodlust thing they're not happy
with following trails
they want to go out and kill animals i
don't understand it but that's just how
they are and we won't stop coming until
it stopped
wherever the hunt goes it is regularly
observed by animal rights activists and
often by hunt saboteurs
well the hunt remains a very divisive
issue campaigners say they won't stop
until such time as scenes like this are
consigned to history
[Applause]
this is a centuries-old tradition its
opponents say the time has now come
to leave it there
ender brady sky news in buckinghamshire